the Joe Rogan experience it's
interesting to the bringing this up that
it's growing on something else and that
that seems to be part of nature right
this sort of symbiotic relationship that
some of these mushrooms have with the
plants and the the environment around
them
that's a really really good point
because the mycelium will be found with
the bees when we grew the mycelium on
rice compared to on birch wood the
mycelium brown rice reduced the viruses
you know ten plus the ten to one the
mycelium we grew it on birch reduced the
viruses up to a thousand to one so
that's a natural environment that that
that speaks the fact that there there
appears to be something that's coding
within the ecosystem that then excites
the mycelium to produce something that
is more strongly result in the antiviral
activity that's the case with cordyceps
as well right cordyceps mushrooms grow
on other things
yeah but the course of the mushrooms
when they grow on the worms this is
something that was a big subject of
debate because because the quarter sep
census is a it's it's it's a mushroom
that grows on a worm basically
caterpillar larva in the Himalayas
elsewhere in China in the Far East and
people were finding these quarter SEPs
mushrooms and they were cloning them and
then they got the culture going and then
they analyzed the culture and they got
what's called an Animorph it's not that
complicated it's just two faces of the
same coin there's a mushroom fruit body
and then there's this imperfect form
that is a different looking organism but
they're actually the same they have two
different expressions when they all the
scientific literature kept on coming up
with different Animorphs and so they all
had all this competition in the
scientific literature what is the true
Animorph of cordyceps sinensis
well now it's called avio cordyceps
sinensis they redefined it's called
sensu stricto and when they analyzed
them the mushrooms
not until recently discovered that
another funk group of fungi are chasing
the cordyceps sinensis
as the fruit body develops other fungi
are chasing right behind the other
fungus so he have multiple fungi that
are actually present in the quarter SEPs
worm it's not just one species it's
multiple species that are are
co-occurring chasing each other in the
inside the the cordyceps mushroom as is
fruits so again it just speaks to the
complexity of nature so what where
should you get your cordyceps source and
for health benefits you know that's a
really good question cordyceps
militarists does not have these issues
that quarter substances does the problem
is quarter substances thousands of
articles have been published really
which one they are talking about it's
like us all mixed up now what is what a
true animal more for these scientists
using mmm there one's called Basilio my
sees you know there's other other ones
that her her see Telus announced this is
now thought to be the true in a more
four quarter substances well this lingo
means is basically there's a mushroom
with a whole bunch of other fungi that
are associated with it and when they
cultured these other fungi they did
clinical studies or research studies and
they came up with results the problem is
that they've mixed it up into four or
five different species and you can't
sort of D a disambiguate the data now
because it's too complicated so it's a
really good question the course EPS
militarists does not have these issues
and so I would steer people to cordyceps
military right now because the course
Epson insists that a Pheo cordyceps
enosis issues are still complicated and
now virtually thousands of research
articles are an all now suspect because
no one has a foggiest idea what Animorph
they were using oh wow so again it
speaks to the complexity of the system
so and how many people are actually
working on this data - of thousands of
researchers and and I'm thankful that
the Chinese mycologist sort of were the
ones who finally sorted this out mm-hmm
there was a lot of conflict academically
there's a lot of big egos in academia
mmm people got wedded to their own
research you know we're all like that
and and the challenges went back and
forth and fortunately a group of Chinese
scientists finally were able to narrow
down their argument
to understand that everyone was actually
doing good culture work they were
actually expert mycologist taking the
right tissue taking it from the right
cordyceps mushroom it's just that at
that time then a different fungus that
was naturally part of the inside of the
mushroom that was a mixture of fungi
that were racing different paces up the
mushroom well the Chinese were the first
to use it for a performance benefit
right
well they were the first to at least be
publicized to use it in the Olympics
they were using cordyceps mushrooms that
was one of the reasons why don it we
developed shroom tech sport which is
cordyceps mushroom based supplement
which I love cordyceps for workouts for
a pre-workout it's like it gives you an
extra gear it's really kind of crazy how
effective it is especially in
combination with b12 and other
adaptogens it just has it's a great
pre-workout supplement because it
doesn't get you jittery at all it's not
a stimulant but you have like a little
more juice when you exercise and that's
one of the things that those
high-altitude hurting populations I
found right that's exactly right it's
likely to be a vasodilator and it has
steroidal like benefits as well so yeah
the quarter sets were for athletes has
been tried and true and many of these
Animorphs that I mentioned have those
properties so for athletes like what
dose would you recommend like well I'm
not a medical doctor so when people ask
me recommendations I know that the
common usage of these in the order of
two grams you know there are usually 500
millimeter milligram capsules there's
lots of good companies that are
producing this you know I would just
make sure it's mycelial based it's not
fruit body-based
of the the clear evidence is showing the
the problem one find out whether
something's my cilia baseships is Claira
we say mushroom mycelium on all of our
labels so and if you were gonna take
that like if you wanted to take shroom
to export if you wanted to make your own
concoction
you would recommend 2 grams and then and
make sure you had no the chain of
custody of where it came from
mm-hmm because a lot of these companies
buy in the spot market what company is
this you gave me most defenseless
defense is this yours yes your company
oh okay we'll support you host defense
and there's
website where someone can grab those
funds Oh calm or Hostos defense calm and
do you sell cordyceps as well yes we do
oh and do you take this stuff before you
exercise do you take absolute assets
yeah I think cordyceps I take lion's
mane and seven species blend in
particular seven species ones what's in
that stuff it's stem at seven it's got a
scotch agha the Scot reishi there's a
gerakan it's got a birch polypore called
a bit the poorest bunch of Linus and so
it has maitake in it and these are the
seven species blend but the the evidence
for physicians and people who want to
look at peer-reviewed articles the
single species have the most elaborated
and convincing evidence when you start
compounding these so what we're doing if
we have five or six full-time
researchers several PhDs on our staff we
are again trying to disambiguate
the complexity of all these benefits by
looking at one species out of time so
we're doing this methodically spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars
literally a year now I have a hundred
and ten employees and I created my
company in order to do research I have
no partners so I can now dedicate the
resources to be able to do novel
research and we love one up against
conventional wisdom because you have to
challenge conventional wisdom to see if
it's indeed meets the mustard
[Applause]